so far I've learned that Dave and DeeDee
I checked out and Zach just does want to
be here tonight a dinner service I'm
curious to see if Dave is actually
holding Gina back in the kitchen so do
you explain the line don't stop working
but okay I work right here in the saute
area and then they serve section doing
the burgers mistakes and Zach he mostly
stands behind the bar so he's not the
rest of manager then he's a bomber it's
supposed to be you went from the bottom
to the top
this summer nothing in between but you
don't get support from it doesn't know
how to doesn't have to
what's the microwave for Gina to heat
the dip up not my choice but not my
choice to do a lot of things you're the
chef right yes so what you say goes
nothing should be some chef
Jesus
[Music]
why us
did you make that no what is that it's
some kind of cheesecake cheesecake looks
like a landmine what year is that from
like 1876 next ticket
Corina please your salad will be right
up
full-time or part-time it's okay to chew
gum in front of customers or they just
let go on no it's very gross and Zach I
know you can't tell sample too but this
young lady's chewing gum I just I mean I
know I know
yes sorry yeah it's not typical Laura
please you spit your gum out thank you
okay you okay yeah I'm fine
sure yeah what's going on here yeah
you're right she didn't have gum
absolutely
excuse me for just one second
what's gonna the ribeye curry go I'm
feeling like a second chef but don't you
talk to each other so the food can hit
the window at the same time if you open
up and talk to are there knocking take
the sauce out of the container and heat
it up in a pot
yeah bill Hanna do me I could do it
right here I got lots of time I'm doing
it man it was a tiny kitchen trying to
expedite this food it's so never needs
to be this hard you know that Gina you
don't like talking do you
it's hard for me when I'm working I'm
sorry but your do desserts tell me young
man do the desserts
yes I know everyone tells me if I need
to relinquish responsibility guys are
more capable you can slice of cheesecake
anyone can do oh you prefer wasting time
do to yourself I know this is it can get
worse the problem with this Lodge is
becoming more apparent
there's just no communication Gina
doesn't speak to the kitchen Dave and
DeeDee ignore the problems and Zach just
doesn't know how to take command so
dysfunctional yes
what's she saying absolutely new chicken
breast please just stop for two seconds
yes sir don't ask but I just want to
touch that touch it it's ice-cold
suppose cool that's what we resulted in
sending your just drowns weight over
your head a mess a big mess and B SS oh
man